you
[Music]
okay perfect hi I'm Caitlin Jordan I'm
here to talk about eight years of making
data science mistakes so just two quick
about me I am lead data scientist at
online meta that's a start-up here in
Austin co-organizer of our ladies Austin
really big fan of that community also
into traveling hiking tacos um
I blog at Caitlin udin comm I tweet at
bianna Posie and I also have a hashtag
des learnings where I track some of the
things that I've been learning and try
to share that with the community so
before we get into all the mistakes I've
made let's talk a little bit about why
we should share our mistakes one thing
that's really important to me is
transparency I think if we were all a
little bit more transparent it would
make our community better I think it
would help fend off a little bit of
imposter syndrome if we admitted things
that we don't know alongside things that
we do I also think it's helpful for
newcomers to see that other people have
faced the same issues that they're
seeing to help other people so I've
learned a ton from other people's
mistakes when I'm implementing new
products the sort of thing it's great to
get advice so I hope that you learned
something today also growth so I am the
sum of all of the mistakes that I've
made up to this point mistakes count as
experience it's how you gain experience
is how you become the analyst or the
person that you eventually are I'm going
to talk about two types of mistakes
mainly today so one is technical
mistakes the other is communication
mistakes I think that people tend to
make a lot more technical mistakes in
the beginning and over time you maybe
make fewer can make communication
mistakes but I think that fundamentally
communication is harder than tech so
we'll cover a little bit of both of
these and we'll cover four sort of
mistake zones so we're gonna start at
the beginning of my career and I was
working as a statistical analyst
it was my job to build predictive models
for nonprofits higher education small
businesses that sort of thing
and I was the first hire at this company
and so before me the CEO had built all
of the models so no pressure there so
this is me when I built my first model I
was super pumped about it very confident
I thought it was good to go I had set up
a meeting to present it to a client this
was after a lot of training I didn't
like start off building models I did a
lot of training first so I had to sit
down with my CEO so that he could review
my work I was ready to go thought it was
good
completely bombed and so he found a
couple of issues with the model that I'd
built I was trying to predict enrollment
so based on students who had been
accepted at a college I was gonna
predict like who would actually accept
that offer and show up in the fall in
doing so I had included two problematic
variables in my model one was deposit so
if you've ever gone to a college before
you can do that you have to make a
deposit that's like a pretty much proxy
for enrollment they have a thing called
summer melt so it's not exactly the same
but highly problematic to have that in a
model the other thing was a variable
called campus visit so any training data
that we have we get after the fact and
so we didn't have enough information to
actually use this variable we had campus
visit but no date some people visit
campus in the fall while they're looking
at schools some people go to like an
accepted students day and we had no way
of knowing whether these people fell
into the former category or the latter
so those were two variables that I
couldn't use I spent about four years at
this company building models and during
that time I made a couple of mistakes um
those mistakes became things that I knew
to look for when I was building models
so I worked in the same areas and those
models started to look similar I started
to get really good at building those
types of models looking for those types
of mistakes so my genius learning is to
look for the usual suspects so as you
start modeling in a particular domain
you'll start to see the same problems
crop up over and over again in your data
for me a lot of that was like
understanding the data source in data
collection I think that's really
important the assumptions that we're
making any filters we're adding missing
values and then understanding the goals
of the model when it was supposed to be
implemented who is supposed to impact
that sort of thing so we're gonna
fast-forward to mistake zone number two
this is communicating with devs so I
moved to Austin started a new role and
as part of that role we were working on
this really cool feature in a product
that was marketed to dentist until
offices so when you cancel an
appointment there is a hole in the
calendar and we wanted to be able to
fill that hole with the person who would
be most likely to take a last minute
appointment I was doing R&D for that
algorithm so I was looking at patterns
in appointment history like do people
tend to always make their appointments
in the morning or on the same day of the
week and so we would ask one question
that would be got more questions and we
went down the rabbit hole one thing that
we found is after we did our first
analysis we realized that there was an
issue with time zones nobody had noticed
it until we were having a conversation
about the data a little while later and
so we did sort of a post-mortem and we
figured out there were three reasons for
that one is that most of the data that I
worked with wasn't time specific it
wasn't like a minute and second specific
it was birthday specific so I think
everyone has to get bit by time zones
once and then you know another was the
way that we set up our analysis hid some
errors so we decided to look at a.m. and
p.m. appointments we didn't count the
number that were happening per hour if
we did we probably would have noticed
this a lot sooner the other issue is
that we had a lack of shared resources
explaining what the data was so any time
I had a question I had to bug a dev ask
them for their explanation I got an oral
history of data which is never good
and as people left the company they took
some of that institutional knowledge
with that was really not fun
eventually we got the fill-in model to a
good place and we were ready to start a
be testing it and so this was the first
time that these devs had worked on a B
testing so we were doing a lot of
communication we were getting everything
set up or really excited and when we got
the results in we started to talk about
what we've done we realized that we ran
an AAA test so we were trying to test
different versions of the algorithm with
our like high users and we actually had
applied the new algorithm to everyone
who was a high user and all of the
people who didn't really use it very
much had the old algorithm so that
didn't work we had to discuss it we had
to go back it was kind of a waste of
time and resources eventually we were
able to do kind of a pre/post so we sort
of saved it but it was a big learning
experience about working with devs for
me so a few things there being willing
to teach and to learn and doing so very
respectfully I've worked in jobs where
people have worked with a lot of data
scientists I've worked in jobs where
people have never worked with a data
scientist before and so you really have
to work with people and find a middle
ground another piece was just don't play
telephone so some of the people who were
actually implementing the a/b test
weren't in the important meetings up
front they were just asked to sort of do
the work they didn't have the full
understanding and that was borne out in
the results another is avoiding jargon
for clarity so I've found that a
computer scientists tend to use
different jargon sometimes they'll say
things like data models that means
something very different than what a
model means to me and so making sure
that we're being very clear about what
we mean and we're actually speaking the
same language has been really important
the other thing is just keeping in mind
that we're all on the same team we all
have the same goals we're all working
towards the same thing so and the third
mistake zone communicating with business
stakeholders the next thing that I was
tasked to do was to figure out the
impact of this new feature so when we
rolled out that feature we expected it
to have an
impact on sales we thought that we would
be able to track you know how many more
sales we sold after we'd rolled out the
future it would be a really easy
analysis we were really excited about it
in talking with the team we realized the
way we would tell the differences the
scripts changed like a sales script
changes when a new feature gets rolled
out we rolled out three features at the
same time and updated them all in the
script so we couldn't actually attribute
any growth to a single feature so we
went on the data adventure and I started
talking to different groups of the
business to see what data they had that
we could use to try to prove that the
work that we've done had had some value
when I did that I encountered a lot of
artisanal data a lot of handcrafted very
lovingly tended to spreadsheets which
were great they meant that this analysis
was not reproducible at this point the
business teams were familiar with the
types of reproduce about reproducible
analyses we could do so we were running
like markdown reports for a B test that
sort of thing they had seen those
outputs they wanted that output to look
every month and see what the impact had
been so this was problematic I thought a
little bit about how to solve this so
what's the best way for me to
communicate the value of this data some
of the data was actually really valuable
some of it was awful those things that I
would never want people to make
decisions on but they had also asked for
it so a secret about me is I was also an
English major I really liked English Lit
language that sort of thing
and this is something I picked up in
those studies so the rhetorical triangle
is a way of framing an argument and so
consists of three parts and the speaker
that's you all the credentials all the
background that you bring along with you
also the way that people see you that's
really important so having sort of some
awareness of how people see analytics
and view within an organization the next
part is the audience so what is the
audience like are they technical are
they non-technical have they been in for
of all of the ins and outs of this
problem are they just there to make
decisions as part of a larger meeting
getting some idea of who you're talking
to will help you to frame their argument
and then the final piece is the context
are you delivering good news or bad news
the things that you're asking for are
they things that people can help with
will they understand the kind of
problems that you have so putting all of
this together has been really helpful
for me whenever I'm talking to people
who are more on the business side of
things to figure out ways that I can
help them and analyses can help them but
we can work together what I came up with
for this particular exercise was a set
of meta metrics and so at the bottom of
every slide I mean sort of like a
stoplight thing that told you if the
data was good if it was trustworthy if
it was a repeatable analysis and they
got this they totally understood it it
was awesome one of the things I found is
for example we go to trade shows and the
way that we were tracking trade show
data was we were hoping that a rep would
tell the manager and then that the
manager would remember to write down
that a sale was the result of this
feature the data was horrible those Reds
all the way across but then they knew
that and so if we wanted to invest in
that data if we wanted to start
analyzing they started to understand why
we needed to put some money in some time
into collecting the data and doing so in
a good way so a few learnings they're
getting stakeholders involved early is
really helpful to get everyone on the
same page as you're working through
these projects and making sure that you
understand the business problem as well
so one thing that's really bad and I
have done before is solving the wrong
business problem or realizing at the end
of an analysis that your model solves
the wrong business problem it's sort of
funny an example of that is that my
first job you're building a model to
predict who would be a major giver and
so that's usually or a sorry like I
bequeath and so that's usually if
someone passes away they give a large
gift to the University or to a museum or
that sort of thing we actually figured
out that our model was predicting death
rather than the gift that would come
after and so that was really bad
so it's just like translating the data
and the business problem that's actually
a really tricky thing and so it's really
helpful to talk to the business
stakeholders to make sure that you're
doing it right
framing analyses in a way that makes
sense so I might be thinking of things
in terms of what they look like in the
database those things might have totally
different colloquial names around the
business and so it's really important
that I'm using the terminology that
other people are using throughout the
business another thing that I personally
am working on and even after years of
making mistakes I still do this all the
time a lot of times you're in a meeting
and people just want to know like who
was in your data set how many people was
it and what did they do I get so wrapped
up in the details of my analysis and
like all the things I want to tell them
that I will often forget like oh yeah it
was 600 people that I looked at and so I
tend to write those things down
inevitably those always come up so
making sure that you know the basic
facts is really helpful
another thing is knowing where they get
their data so I've worked at companies
where the BI system is different than
the data that the analysts work with
unlike data analysts or devs or that
sort of thing that can be really
problematic so if you have people in the
c-suite or stakeholders who are looking
at reports coming out of a system that
you don't use your numbers not going to
match and so understanding where they
get their data perfect and how you can
explain why your data might be different
is really important if you want to get
everyone on the same page one last
problem that we'll talk about is
infrastructure and team so one of the
roles that I took on was to work on the
algorithm so we had a company
a large portion of their business ran on
this single a set of machine learning
algorithms that were in production the
fact that we refer to it as the
algorithm should tell you sort of
everything you need to know about what
the rest of the business under
good about how this all worked so we had
a couple of data scientists leave at the
same time one of them was lucky enough
to sit down with us and spend a whole
week teaching us how the algorithm
worked the ins and outs that sort of
thing
when it came time for us to pick up the
algorithm and just continue to work with
it it was super scary um we did not have
the documentation that we actually
needed to be able to understand the
algorithm like inside out so we had to
spend a ton of time trying to engineer
the code figure out where these things
came from and then explain it to other
people so one of the things that we did
is wrote up some pseudocode and I've
been doing this ever since for anything
that's related to machine learning or
there might be a little bit tougher for
people to understand so it's taking the
ideas like the inputs the outputs the
business problem you're trying to solve
and putting them into plain English and
these documents can live close to the
code or separately from the code I've
even written pseudocode documents for
different audiences so one for engineers
who understand the databases I'm talking
about that sort of thing and then one
for business people who need to
understand the basics of the algorithm
sort of what it's doing to be able to
explain it in a business context so some
learnings around infrastructure and team
I can't stress documentation enough I've
written a little bit about data
dictionaries and sequel query libraries
those have been really helpful
especially for making sure that you're
not duplicating work if you are working
with different queries to find the
number of active clients for example
that should be a really simple problem
it's amazing how many times I've seen
this done differently by different
people in the same organization so doing
things like code reviews can help you
with that making sure that everyone's on
the same page if they know the ins and
outs of certain systems that those are
being communicated to the whole team
another thing is core team meetings so
when I first started working at one
particular job our analysis team was a
little bit siloed and then we started
working with more and more teams one of
the best things we ever did was get into
these core team meetings so it was
business stakeholders we would have like
someone from
Marketing the head of product someone
from engineering someone from data
someone from customer service all of
those people the heads of state of a
single product would come together once
a week just for an hour over lunch and
just kind of talk about the product
things that were coming out but it was
great because we always had the most
up-to-date information about what was
going on any issues that other teams
were seeing especially for data analysis
that context is key is really crucial to
be able to do the right kinds of
analysis and then pseudocode pseudocode
helps everyone it's really helpful
documentation to have so I promise a
little bit of advice I have just one
slide so aspiring data scientists learn
sequel communication is a technical
skill is every bit as hard as anything
else that's technical start a blog I
think Dave Robinson's going to talk a
little bit more about that later on but
I love that advice teach others you
learn concepts more deeply when you
teach them yourself don't worry about
learning everything at first and find
your community community's really
helpful for helping to learn stay
curious have fun don't be afraid to use
Google and remember that everybody is
winging it Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]